the us election is taking up air time on
russian state television as the ballots
are still being counted
globally
systems
four days after election day the
associated press and other media outlets
declared former vice president joe biden
the winner
he had garnered the 270 electoral votes
needed to defeat president trump in the
race for the white house
but russia's main television networks
are taking extra effort to cast out on
biden's victory in the eyes of its
viewers
russian state networks are using the
elections as an opportunity to portray
american democracy as messy
state chestnut occupies an enormous role
in the russian media landscape
in terms of informing people and
informing opinions it really does
play a very large role there are three
main themes shaping russian public
opinion about u.s politics
such as election irregularities the
question about who calls the winner
and the stark preview of the new
administration
there's no apparent coordination between
russian state media and the trump
campaign but russian media have echoed a
familiar line from the trump campaign
about election irregularities
it's amazing how those mail-in ballots
are so one-sided
foreign
there has been no evidence of widespread
fraud but the trump campaign has turned
to the courts
challenging absentee and mail-in voting
procedures
while the newscasts appear to support
trump and not biden
it's ultimately signaling something else
to viewers
i think that a big part of this is not
really to come down on one side or the
other
but to rather kind of so doubt in
people's minds about the
electoral process about the nature of
democracy itself in the united states
russian anchors also have questions
about who's calling the results in the
u.s
for over a century u.s presidential
elections have been called by news
organizations before the official
results are announced
that's because it can take weeks to
certify the results since each state has
different rules and regulations
nbc news now projects news organizations
based their calls on near complete vote
counts by election officials in each
state
plus the u.s doesn't have a national
elections commission to announce the
winner
but in russia there's a central election
commission
and so to russian viewers the american
way of calling the election is unusual
who was it called by all the oh my
goodness
all the networks wow
biden's critical comments about russia
over the years out of ukraine
are repeated across different political
shows he's portrayed as someone who will
not be nice or at least neutral to
russia
biden frequently criticized russia's
foreign policy and strongly supported
sanctioning moscow for annexing
ukraine's crimean peninsula in 2014
the focus isn't just on biden but also
people possibly being considered to join
his administration
that certainly does get across the idea
that joe biden is not the favored
candidate of the kremlin
given some of the things that biden has
said about russia i think the biggest
threat
to america right now in terms of
breaking up our
our security and our alliances is russia
but biden has also indicated a
willingness to work with the kremlin on
the extension of an arms control treaty
something that moscow has also shown
interest in
seriousness
nearly three out of four russians get
their news from television
and so the message that state media
broadcasts send about the future
administration
reaches large audiences across russia
beyond who sits in the white house
russia's rolling coverage of the
election
has a deeper message about american
democracy
americans that with its constantly
changing
political landscape it isn't one to be
envied
the more time passes the more you see
the differences between
the u.s political system and the russian
political system which
in name calls itself a democracy things
stay very much the same in russia and i
think
the idea that they're trying to get
across here is that you have
this kind of vibrant democracy
but it's flawed at its roots and and so
that in the end kind of leaves the
russian people no alternative to imagine
a russian political system that could be
anything else beyond
vladimir putin staying in power